um speaking of Trump what would you give
him as a grade kind of through this
whole thing right are we talking a plus
a minus B plus C minus one would kind of
the great beat I think decompose I think
in February you know C and then say C
instead of worse because you look at
what many other Western Democratic
leaders did in February specifically
wasn't it better in March actually I'm
not sure what else he could have done I
mean he's got his usual misstatements
insulting you know something for some
errors and stuff he doesn't always
express things as clearly cogently as he
should and precisely but the fundamental
policies of the administration starting
in March seem pretty damn accurate even
Biden has many sounds but he hasn't
everything exactly what he would have
done differently in March other than the
tweet bus you know and if you're eight
people less and be more sympathetic
because he can't even I feel also
starting in March I don't think he would
have done differently so I think it's
started and in the administration time
together he's been pretty damn good
pretty damn thoughtful pretty aggressive
and you know he's trying to innovate
trying to suspend regulations that
didn't make any sense for town for the
FDA historically in the United States
you couldn't doctors between across
state lines so we needed more doctors
than you are California doctors can help
but yeah you know make that possible
these are temporary basis so a lot of
positive innovation around the
regulatory constraints has been driven
by the administration and that thing is
do you think hopefully some of those
will persist I mean it makes no sense
the doctors in California can't treat
patients in New York as if there's a
regional variation and you know the
perfect standard of care that makes no
sense it's very different actually so in
any event I think the grades get better
over time not but I don't know that too
many people you know how great grades in
February other than some people in Asian
countries particularly in Taiwan to some
extent
less a little bit more mixed in
Singapore Israel seems to have been slow
to the game but very thoughtful and very
productive starting March so it depends
on the country really but I don't think
anybody other than really like the
Taiwan's New Zealand although it's kind
of a different demographic Geographic
you know dispersion there's a lot of
issues and you still have been feelings
obviously handle this extremely well
yeah